And everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another edition of Cutters,
clinic live. Today, we're going to be talking about brain inflammation because
brain inflammation causes inflammation everywhere in your body. And many times a person could have
chronic pain that is actually caused from inflammation of the brain. And it really does nothing to do
with the area that they have pain. You see that coming with mold patients, coming with Lyme patients,
where they can have pain that seems to migrate. It's in my right knee this week and now my right
knee is fine. And my left ankle hurts next week. And why is this? Is it the Lyme that's moving
around? Is it the mold that's moving around? Or a biotoxid? What? The world is going out of what
has to do with inflammation of the pride a little bit. The brain or other areas of the brain
thereby it affects what where that neurology goes. Brain inflammation causes a whole lot of other
things too, because we're going to see in just a second as well. Brain inflammation can be the cause
of cancer. So you know, that's a scary thing right there. Diabetes, obesity, autoimmune diseases,
muscle issues, nerve diseases, as well as things that you would normally think of like headaches and
things like that. But brain inflammation could cause all sorts of emotional issues. Dementia
is caused from a source of brain inflammation, anxiety, depression. So there's so many things that
encompass inflammation of the brain because the brain controls everything in the body. So let's just
jump into how we can help reduce brain inflammation. But I get into the causes so much here, but how
could we reduce brain inflammation? We only have so much time in this little episode. Well number one
is sleep. Sleep is important to reduce brain inflammation because here's a cross section of the brain
here, the outside surface of the brain here and all your brain cells in here. And during the day
and in a wake time, your cerebral spinal fluid doesn't really profuse deep into the brain. But while we
sleep, the cerebral spinal fluid profuses deep into the brain. It helps wash the brain clean.
So the glial cells actually shrink when we're sleeping. They contract. And then your cerebral spinal fluid
is able to profuse deeper into the brain. And literally that cerebral spinal fluid washes through
the open spaces of the brain. And it basically scrubs our brain clean. That's the problem when we don't
get sleep. We can literally just become incoherent. So sleep is so important to get rid of toxins
in the brain. Your glial cells and your axons and your neurons produce waste as their function,
just like any other cells of the body, a little bit differently, but they still produce waste. And that
waste has to be exited. This is what's called your glimphatic system where it's your glial cells
shrinking, causing cerebral spinal fluid to flow through the brain to help clean the brain. Whereas in
the rest of the body, you have a lymphatic system. If the brain you don't have that same lymphatic
system, it's actually has to do with glial contractions, what's called your glimphatic system.
Kind of neat. Sleep is important. We can't overemphasize that. So those who love sleep out there,
here's your excuse to sleep. And it's even followed that taking naps during the day, this can take place.
So even short sleep periods, this can take place. So another kudos to our nappers out there.
Number two is to decrease your sympathetic nervous system tone.
What does that mean? Well, you have two different parts of your autonomic nervous system,
your ANS, your autonomic nervous system thinking that as your automatic nervous system.
You have your sympathetic and your parasympathetic. Your sympathetic and your parasympathetic and
they work kind of opposites. So the heart, the sympathetic increases your heart rate. It increases
the force of contraction. I like to tell people, think of as polar bear jumped out in front of you,
you want to have a very healthy sympathetic nervous system. Polar bear jumps down in front of you.
You better have an increased heart rate to be able to run away from that polar bear.
You better have an increased force of contraction. Push blood through,
down to your extremities, down to your legs so that you can run really fast and get away from that.
You have blood vessel constriction so that blood oxygen can flow quite quickly.
Through the bloodstream, therefore, you're going to have an increased blood pressure.
You're going to have bronchidolation. You need to get an oxygen into my lungs quite quickly because
I'm going to be running away from that polar bear. And in the gut, you're going to have decreased
motility, sphincter contraction. We don't need to have a bowel right now, decreased secretions. I
don't need to worry about digesting any food correctly right now. I don't need to move anything
through the bowel. All my energy has to go into getting rid of my problem, which is running away
from that polar bear. Your parasympathetic nervous system really functions in the exact opposite.
Forgive my cold today, I apologize. It's a decreased heart rate.
Slow is your heart rate. Decreases the force of contraction. It really has a little
factor in the blood vessel. Now, it's believed that there are some vasodilation going on with
parasympathetic stimulation, bronchial constriction. There's no need to have excessive
dilation, increased motility, sphincter relaxation, increased secretions. So in a parasympathetic state,
we're digesting our food, we're detoxifying, our liver is functioning well,
where this is a normal state that we want to be in without life crisis. If we're stuck in this
constant crisis mode here, this is not a good thing. We're not going to be digesting our food,
we're not going to be detoxified, we're going to have high blood pressure, we're going to live in
this sympathetic tone, high stress, a lot of inflammation throughout the rest of the body as well,
not just the brain, and that is very, very unhealthy. So how do we decrease this sympathetic
total? I have a couple of handouts that we give our patients. The sympathetic nervous system is
housed in a part of the brain called the messencephalon. That's why this handout is titled this,
that's something you need to know, but how do you need to decrease sympathetic tone? There's ways
just from a functional neurology point of view to decrease that messencephalon, messencephalon,
tone, and they seem kind of weird, but they actually work and there's a lot of research behind them.
We're in rose colored glasses, it's not just rose colored glasses, even sun glasses can help
decrease sympathetic tone. Matter of fact, people that are stuck in a higher sympathetic tone tend
to have more sensitivity to light because their pupils are more dilated in a sympathetic tone as well.
I didn't show on the last slide, but that is one thing with sympathetic tone. Your pupils
are going to be dilated because you've got to see where you're ready to get away from that polar bear.
So wearing sunglasses can help calm the sympathetic nervous system.
Placing a cotton ball in your right ear because it fires back, the way it fires back neurologically,
it can decrease the messencephalon and decrease sympathetic tone.
Breathing a foul smell, whatever you consider foul in your right nostril, closing your left nostril
with your finger and putting a smell up to your dirty sock or something like that up to your
right nostril will stimulate, call me that sympathetic nervous system.
Hubby or gargling, we'll talk about that in just a second, slow, deep, belly breathing,
slows the sympathetic tone down. Stimulating the frontal lobe, the prefrontal cortex,
typically the right prefrontal cortex, in playing memory games, like card games,
just like solitary type card games where you lay the cards down and here's another jack, or that's a
kick, and that that can stimulate a depression in sympathetic tone. If you have a chimishine,
this can be helpful. Using a vibration tool, like if you have one of those standout foot vibrators
where you stand out an exercise, which is standing on that foot vibration or even a handheld
vibrator that you can get at target or something like that, your lower extremities can stimulate
to call the sympathetic nervous system. Dietary concerns that help stimulate the
slow, the sympathetic is glutamate, looking at glutamate issues. Glutamates are found in prepared foods,
modusodium glutamate is what you probably heard of, but eating tons of meat also because it contains
glutamate and will convert to glutamate can be an issue. Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter,
so that's the problem with them. If I consume glutamates, MSG and my foods, I have this excess amount
of excitatory neurotransmitter, and it's going to stimulate the mesencephalic tone because of the
mesencephaline, the sympathetic are controlled through glutamate. Any inflammatory foods
can cause an increased mesencephalic tone as well, like glutamate and dairy. You have glutamate and
casio-morphine receptors in the gut that can stimulate back to the brain, so cutting back on glutamate
and dairy and even histamines can help calm the sympathetic. These are more long term things that you
could do if you're under a very stressful period of your life for some reason. Looking at dietary
things can be extremely helpful. Cleaning up your diet, getting rid of prepared foods in your diet,
cutting back on glutamate to the dairy, cutting back on histamines in your diet can really help
calm a person's mood, can help calm that sympathetic, hyper-total that you're dealing with.
And then other emotional things, the mesencephaline and the amygdala are very closely related.
Your amygdala is where you house all your emotional memories and past emotional traumas, past physical
traumas. You can come up in the amygdala and they stimulate that stimulates the mesencephaline,
which is going to increase sympathetic. So dealing with that, getting some counseling,
dealing with that can be helpful as well. This is another handout we use on how to stimulate the
vagal nerve. The vagus is your parasympathetic. So if you go back to this slide, remember your sympathetic
and parasympathetic. We're trying to decrease this and we're trying to increase this when we're
dealing with inflammation of the brain. So anything you could do to stimulate vagal nerve,
well there's found that gargolene, what like an eighth a cup of water, 12 times a day for 60 seconds
and you've got a gargle really fairly aggressively in order for it to really stimulate the vagus nerve.
Anything you do to stimulate the gang reflex, just kind of sticking a little, your fingernail,
your throat a little bit, to feel like you're going to vomit almost. Stimulated the gang reflex,
the gang reflex is from cranial nerve 10. You are stimulating the vagus nerve and you will help
calm the sympathetic. Coffee enemas or even probiotic enemas can also be very beneficial. We talk
about coffee enemas for cancer patients and how good it is to help flush out the liver,
but maybe one of the most beneficial things about coffee enemas is it's a great cranial nerve 10
stimulation. Even singing and humming and such can be a good cranial nerve 10 stimulation as well,
so those are good things to do. Now he's looking at the spiritual aspect of things we can be so
stressed and stuck on a sympathetic tone has to do with not really grounding ourselves from a
spiritual point of view and we like to talk about making sure that you are seeking that out as well.
You cannot ignore the gut-brain interaction. Any inflammation of the gut equals inflammation of
the brain. So if you have any food sensitivities that you may not even know about, I don't have
sensitivities because it doesn't affect me at all. My stomach feels fine, I could eat a horse and my
stomach has no issues whatsoever, but inflammation of the gut you may not feel in the gut can cause
inflammation of the brain and it can cause issues elsewhere. So you eat gluten and you have
chronic pain, but you do have any gut problems. So people have a hard time putting those two things
together and you have to just understand the physiology period that got of the brain. So looking at food
sensitivities, getting a sensitivity test done can be extremely helpful dealing with antibiotic use,
the probiotics and healing the gut. Healing the gut should be on everybody's radar is one of the
top things you do. Changing the brain's chemistry, we're not going to spend a lot of time with this,
but looking at neurotransmitter balance, you can get tested for this, looking at other immune
responses that could be taking place in the brain, and of course you have to deal with sources. So if I
have a Lyme disease or a mole toxicity or something like that, then I'm not dealing with that.
All these things that I'm telling you today can be helpful, but you do need to deal with that
source of inflammation as well. Durofeedback is another thing that we've used in our office,
and now we're using just a head held machine that people can put these glasses on and do it home.
Very inexpensive for about $500. You can get a nice little machine that can really help you sleep.
If that's all it does is help you sleep. It's already combating our biggest problem here,
because it can help you detox your brain, and it's a great little tool and we sell it at our store,
and then there's also things that you could do to help mimic sleep. So you can mimic sleep
through different nutrients that are called central alpha and agonists. So CAA's central alpha
agonists, and there's natural supplements that are central alpha agonists that can help reduce
your sympathetic tone as well. I list them here. I will go through them all.
Other ones to consider are adding ACE inhibitors, natural ACE inhibitors. Now normally you think
of an ACE inhibitor for somebody who has high blood pressure, but even if you don't have high blood
pressure, using natural ACE inhibitors like Hawthorne, Picatinol, Palma granite, omega-3s,
and melatonin can be extremely beneficial to reduce sympathetic tone as well. And now CBD oil
has been shown to be extremely beneficial to reduce sympathetic tone, and that's why it helps
with decreasing anxiety. It really helps decrease glutamate levels of the brain too. So we are
really hot on CBD oil and use a lot of that with our patients. It's probably the number one
thing that we use with our patients at CBD oil. Very beneficial. Really has no side effects,
has no downsides, and can use it with even teeny little babies. So it's a great product to use
for that. So your take home today is really, you want to reduce inflammation in your brain,
and sleep is your, what are your biggest allies here? So anything you can do to increase sleep,
improve sleep, take naps will be most beneficial. Emotionally, ground yourself in decreasing your
sympathetic tone. We touch on that very heavily at this few minutes that we had together.
Spiritual grounding, healing your gut, do not ignore that part. So any inflammation of the gut is
going to cause brain inflammation. You could do all these other exercises, but you got the source of
inflammation constantly wrapping up in your brain. You're going to regret it. And then you
utilize it's a nutrients to mimic sleep like the CBD oil and the ACE and natural ACE inhibitors
would be very beneficial as well. All right, thanks for joining me and we'll see you next time.